let's go ahead and understand
text mining in detail let's first
understand what text mining
is text mining is the technique of
exploring large amounts of unstructured
text
data and analyzing it in order to
extract patterns from the texted data
it is aided by software that can
identify concepts
patterns topics keywords and other
attributes in the data
it utilizes computational techniques to
extract
and summarize the high quality
information from
unstructured textual resources
let's understand the flow of text mining
there are five techniques used in text
mining system
information extraction or text
pre-processing
this is used to examine the unstructured
text
by searching out the important words and
finding the relationships between them
categorization or text transformation
attribute generation
categorization technique labels the text
document under one or more categories
classification of text data is done
based on
input output examples with
categorization
clustering or attribute selection
clustering method is used to group text
documents that have similar content
clusters are the partitions
and each cluster will have a number of
documents with
similar content clustering makes sure
that no document will be omitted from
the search
and it derives all the documents that
have similar content
visualization technique the process of
finding relevant information is
simplified by visualization
technique this technique uses text flags
to represent a group of documents
or a single document and compactness is
indicated using colors
visualization technique helps to display
textual
information in a more attractive way
summarization or
interpretation or evaluation
summarization technique will help to
reduce the length of the document
and summarize the details of the
documents it makes the document
easy to read for users and understand
the content
at the moment let's understand the
significance of text
mining document clustering
document clustering is an important part
of text mining it has many applications
in knowledge management
and information retrieval clustering
makes it easy to group similar documents
into meaningful groups
such as in newspapers where sections are
often grouped as business sports
politics and so on
pattern identification text mining is
the process of automatically searching
large amount of text
for text patterns and recognition of
features
features such as telephone numbers and
email addresses can be extracted using
pattern matches
product insights text mining helps to
extract large amounts of text
for example customer reviews about the
products
mining consumer reviews can reveal
insights like most loved feature
most hated feature improvements required
and reviews of competitors products
security monitoring
text mining helps in monitoring and
extracting information
from news articles and reports for
national security purposes
text mining makes sure to use all of
your available information
it is a more effective and productive
knowledge discovery
that allows you to make better informed
decisions automate information intensive
processes
gather business critical insights and
mitigate operational risk
let's look at the applications of text
mining
speech recognition speech recognition is
the recognition and
translation of spoken language into text
and vice versa
speech often provides valuable
information about the topics subjects
and concepts of multimedia content
information extraction from speech is
less complicated
yet more accurate and precise than
multimedia content
this fact motivates content-based speech
analysis for multimedia data mining and
retrieval
where audio and speech processing is a
key enabling technology
spam filtering spam detection is an
important method in which
textual information contained in an
email
is extracted and used for discrimination
text mining is useful in automatic
detection of spam emails based on the
filtering content
using text mining an email service
provider such as gmail or yahoo
mail checks the content of an email and
if some malicious text is found
in the mail then that email is marked as
spam and sent to the spam folder
sentiment analysis it is done in order
to determine if a given sentence
expresses
positive neutral or negative sentiments
sentiment analysis is
one of the most popular applications of
text analytics
the primary aspect of sentiment analysis
includes data analysis of the body of
the text
for understanding the opinion expressed
by it and other key factors comprising
modality and mood usually the process of
sentiment analysis works best
on text that has a subjective context
then on that with only an objective
context
e-commerce personalization text mining
is used to suggest
products that fit into a user's profile
text mining
is increasingly being used by e-commerce
retailers
to learn more about the consumers as it
is the process of analyzing textual
information
in order to identify patterns and gain
insights
e-commerce retailers can target specific
individuals or segments
with personalized offers and discounts
to boost
sales and increase customer loyalty by
identifying customer purchase patterns
and opinions
on particular products let's look at
natural language toolkit library in
detail
natural language toolkit is a set of
open source python models
that are used to apply statistical
natural language processing
on human language data let's see how you
can do
environment setup of nltk
go to windows start and launch python
interpreter from
anaconda prompt and enter the following
commands
enter command python to check the
version of python installed on your
system
enter import nltk to link you to the
nltk library available to download
then enter nltk.download function that
will open the nltk
download window check the download
directory
select all packages and click on
download
this will download nltk onto your python
once you have downloaded the nltk you
must
check the working and functionality of
it in order to test the setup enter the
following command in python idle
from nltk dot corpus
import brown brown dot word
parenthesis parenthesis the brown is an
nltk corpus that shows the systematic
difference
between different genres available words
function will give you the list
available words in the genre
the given output shows that we have
successfully tested
the nltk installed on python
let's now understand how you can read a
specific module from
nltk corpora if you want to import an
entire module from
nltk corpora use asterisk
symbol with that module name import
command
enter the command from nltk.book import
asterisk
it will load all the items available in
nltk's book module
now in order to explore brown corpus
enter the command
nltk dot corpus import brown
this will import brown corpus on the
python
enter brown dot categories function to
load the different
genres available select a genre and
assign that genre to a variable using
the following syntax
variable name is equal to brown dot
words
categories is equal to genre name now in
order to see the available words inside
the selected genre
just enter the defined variable name as
a command
let's understand text extraction and
pre-processing in detail
so let's first understand the concept of
tokenization
tokenization is the process of removing
sensitive data
and placing unique symbols of
identification
in that place in order to retain all the
essential information
concerned with the data by its security
it is a process of breaking running
streams of text into words and
sentences it works by segregating words
using
punctuation and spaces
text extraction and pre-processing
n-grams
now let's look at what n-gram is and how
it is helpful in text mining
n-gram is the simplest model that
assigns these probabilities
to sequences of words or sentences
n-grams are combinations of adjacent
words or letters of length
and in the source text so engram is very
helpful
in text mining when it is required to
extract patterns from the text
as in the given example this is a
sentence
all of these words are considered
individual words
and thus represent unigrams a
2 gram or bigram is a two-word sequence
of words like this is
is a or a sentence and a 3-gram or
trigram is a three-word sequence of
words like
this is a or is a sentence
let's now understand what stop words are
and how you can remove them
stop words are natural language words
that have negligible meanings such as
a and and or
the and other similar words these words
also will take up space in the database
or increase the processing time
so it is better to remove such words by
storing a list of stop words
you can find the list of stop words in
the nltk data directory that is stored
in 16 different languages
use the following command to list the
stop words of english language defined
in
nltk corpus importing nltk will
import the nltk corpus for that instance
enter from nltk.corpus import
stopwords will import stopwords from
nltk
corpus now set the language as english
so use set function as set under braces
stop
words dot words set genre as english
stop words are filtered out before
processing of natural language data
as they don't reveal much information so
as you can see in the given example
before filtering the sentence the
tokenization of stop word
is processed in order to remove these
stop words
and the filtering is applied in order to
filter the sentence based on some
criteria
text extraction and pre-processing
stemming
stemming is used to reduce a word to
stem or base word by removing suffixes
such as
helps helping help and helper to the
root word help
the stemming process or algorithm is
generally called a stemmer
there are various stemming algorithms
such as porter stemmer
lancaster stemmer snowball stemmer etc
use any of the stemmers defined under
nltk stem corpus
in order to perform stemming as shown in
the example
here we have used porter stemmer when
you observe the output you will see that
all of the words given
have been reduced to their root word or
stem
text extraction and pre-processing
limitization
lemmatization is the method of grouping
the various inflected types of a word
in order that they can be analyzed as
one item
it uses vocabulary list or a
morphological analysis to get the root
word
it uses wordnet database that has
english
words linked together by their semantic
relationship
as you can observe the given example the
different words
have been extracted to their relevant
morphological word using
limitization text extraction and
pre-processing pos tagging
let's now look at different part of
speech tags available in the national
language toolkit library
a pos tag is a special label assigned to
each token or word
in a text corpus to indicate the part of
speech
and often also other grammatical
categories such as tense
number either plural or singular case
etc
pos tags are used in text analysis tools
and algorithms and also in corpus
searches
so look at the given example here alice
wrote a program
is the source text given the pos tags
given are alice is a noun
wrote is a verb a is an article and
program
is an adjective look at the given
example to understand how pos tags are
defined
so the given sentence or paragraph
contains different words that represent
different parts of speech we will first
use tokenization and removal of stop
words
and then allocate the different pos tags
these are shown with different words
in the given sentence pos tags are
useful
for lemmatization in building named
entity recognition
and extracting relationships between
words
text extraction and pre-processing named
entity recognition
now let's understand what named entity
recognition is all about
ner seeks to extract a real world entity
from the text
and sorts it into pre-defined categories
such as names of people
organizations locations etc many
world questions can be answered with the
help of name entity recognition
were specified products mentioned in
complaints or reviews
does the tweet contain the name of a
person does the tweet contain the
person's address
as you can see in the given example
google america
larry page etc are the names of a person
place or an organization
so these are considered named entities
and have different tags
such as person organization gpe
or geopolitical entity etc
nlp process workflow
now you have an understanding of all
nltk tools
so now let's understand the natural
language processing workflow
step 1 tokenization it splits
text into pieces tokens or words and
removes punctuation
step 2 stop word removal it removes
commonly used
words such as the is are etc
which are not relevant to the analysis
step 3 stemming and limitization
it reduces words to base form in order
to be analyzed as a single item
step 4 pos tagging it tags words to be
part of speech
such as noun verb adjective etc based on
the definition
and context step 5 information retrieval
it extracts relevant information from
the source
mo1 brown corpus problem statement
the brown university standard corpus of
present-day american english
also known popularly as brown corpus was
compiled in the 1960s
as a general corpus in the field of
corpus linguistics
it contains 500 samples of english
language text
totaling roughly 1 million words
compiled from works published in the
united states in nineteen sixty one
we will be working on one of the subset
data set and perform text processing
tasks
let us import the nltk library and read
the ca
underscore 10 corpus import nltk
we will have to make sure that there are
no slashes in between
hence we will use the replace function
within pandas for the same
let's have a look at the data once
tokenization after performing sentence
tokenization on the data we obtain
similarly after applying sentence
tokenizer the
resulting output shows all individual
words
tokens
word removal let's import the stop word
library
from nltk.corpus import stop
words we also need to ensure that the
text is in the same case
nltk has its own list of stop words
we can check the list of stop words
using stop words dot words
and english inside the parenthesis
map the lowercase string with our list
of word tokens
let's remove the stop words using the
english stop words list in
nltk we will be using set checking as it
is faster in python than a list
by removing all stop words from the text
we obtain
often we want to remove the punctuations
from the documents too
since python comes with batteries
included we have a string dot
punctuation
from string import punctuation
combining the punctuation with the stop
words from nltk
removing stop words with punctuation
stemming and limitization we will be
using
stemming and limitization to reduce
words to their root form
for example walks walking walk will be
reduced to their root word walk
importing porter stemmer as the stemming
library
from nltk.stem import porter stemmer
printing the stem words
import the wordnet lemmitizer from
nltk.stem
printing the root words
we also need to evaluate the pos tags
for each token
create a new word list and store the
list of word tokens against each of the
sentence tokens in data too
for i in tokenized
also we will check if there were any
stop words in the recently created word
list
we will now tag the word tokens
accordingly using the pos
tags and print the tagged output
for our final text processing task we
will be applying
named entity recognition to classify
named entities in text
into predefined categories such as the
names of persons
organizations locations expressions of
times quantities
monetary values percentages etc
now press the tagged sentences under the
chunk parser
if we set the parameter binary equals
true
then named entities are just tagged as
ne
otherwise the classifier adds category
labels such as person
organization and gpe
create a function named as extract
entity names along with an empty list
named as entity names
we will now extract named entities from
a nltk
chunked expression and store them in the
empty created above
again we will set the entity names list
as an empty list
and will extract the entity names by
iterating over
each tree in chunked sentences
great we have seen how to explore and
examine
the corpus using text processing
techniques
let's quickly recap the steps we've
covered so far
one import the nltk library
two perform tokenization three perform
stemming and dilemmatization
four remove stop words five perform
named entity recognition structuring
sentences
syntax let's first understand what
syntax is
syntax is the grammatical structure of
sentences
in the given example this can be
interpreted as syntax
and it is similar to the ones you use
while writing codes
knowing a language includes the power to
construct phrases and
sentences out of morphemes and words
the part of the grammar that represents
a speaker's knowledge of these
structures and their formation is called
syntax
phrase structure rules are rules that
determine what goes into a phrase
that is constituents of a phrase and how
the constituents are ordered
constituent is a word or group of words
that operate as a unit
and can be used to frame larger
grammatical units
the given diagram represents that a noun
phrase is determined when a noun is
combined with a determiner
and the determiner can be optional a
sentence is determined when a noun
phrase is combined with a verb phrase
a verb phrase is determined when a verb
is combined optionally with the noun
phrase
and prepositional phrase and a
prepositional phrase is determined when
a preposition is combined with a noun
phrase
a tree is a representation of
syntactic's structure of formulation of
sentences or
strings consider the given sentence the
factory employs 12.8 percent of bradford
county
what can be the syntax for pairing this
statement
let's understand this a tree is produced
that might help you understand
that the subject of the sentence is the
factory
the predicate is employees and the
target
is 12.8 percent which in turn is
modified by bradford county
syntax parses are often a first step
toward deep information extraction
or semantic understanding of text
rendering syntax trees
download the corresponding.exe file to
install the ghost script rendering
engine based on your system
configuration
in order to render syntax trees in your
notebook
let's understand how you can set up the
environment variable
once you have downloaded and installed
the file go to the folder where it is
installed and copy the path of the file
now go to system properties and under
advanced properties
you will find the environment variable
button click on that to open the pop-up
box tab
of the environment now open the bin
folder
and add the path to the bin folder in
your environment variables
now you will have to modify the path of
the environment variable
use the given code to test the working
of syntax tree
after the setup is successfully
installed
structuring sentences chunking and chunk
parsing
the process of extraction of phrases
from unstructured text is called
chunking
instead of using just simple tokens
which may not represent the actual
meaning of the text
it is advisable to use phrases such as
indian team
as a single word instead of indian and
team
as separate words the chunking
segmentation refers to identifying
tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct tag
these chunks correspond to mixed
patterns in some way to extract patterns
from chunks we need
chunk parsing the chunk parsing segment
refers to identifying strings of tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct chunk
type let's look at the given example
you can see here that yellow is an
adjective dog is a noun
and the is the determiner which are
chunked together into a noun
phrase similarly chunk parsing is used
to extract patterns
and to process such patterns from
multiple chunks while using different
parsers
let's take an example and try to
understand how chunking is performed in
python
let's consider the sentence the little
mouse ate the fresh
cheese assigned to a variable named
scent
using the word tokenize function under
nltk corpora
you can find out the different tags
associated with the sentence provided
so as you can see in the output
different tags have been allocated
against
each of the words from the given
sentence using chunking
np chunk and parser
you will now create grammar from a noun
phrase and will mention the tags you
want in your chunk phrase
within the function here you have
created a regular expression matching
the string
the given regular expression indicates
optional determiner followed by optional
number of adjective followed by a noun
you will now have to parse the chunk
therefore you will create a chunk
parser and pass your noun phrase string
to it
the parser is now ready you will use the
parse
parenthesis parenthesis within your
chunk parser to parse your sentence
the sentence provided is the little
mouse ate the fresh cheese
this sentence has been parsed and the
tokens that match the regular
expressions
are chunked together into noun phrases
np
create a verb phrase chunk using regular
expressions
the regular expression has been defined
as optional personal pronoun
followed by zero or more verbs with any
of its type
followed by any type of adverb you'll
now create another chunk
parser and pass the verb phrase string
to it
create another sentence and tokenize it
add pos
tags to it so the new sentence is
she is walking quickly to the mall and
the pos tag has been allocated from
nltk corpora now use the new verb
phrase parser to parse the tokens and
run the results
you can look at the given tree diagram
which shows a verb parser where a
pronoun
followed by two verbs and an adverb are
chunked together
into a verb parse structuring sentences
chinking chinking is the process of
removing a sequence of tokens from a
chunk
how does chunking work the whole chunk
is removed when the sequence of tokens
spans an entire chunk if the sequence is
at the start or the end of the chunk
the tokens are removed from the start
and end
and a smaller chunk is retained if the
sequence of tokens appears in the middle
of the chunk
these tokens are removed leaving two
chunks where there was only one before
consider you create a chinking grammar
string containing three things
chunk name the regular expression
sequence of a chunk
the regular expression sequence of your
[ __ ]
here in the given code we have the chunk
regular expression
as optional personal pronoun followed by
zero
or more occurrences of any type of the
verb type
followed by zero or more occurrences
of any of the adverb types the [ __ ]
regular expression says that it needs to
check for the adverb in the extracted
chunk
and remove it from the chunk inside the
chinking block with open curly braces
and closing curly braces you have
created one or more adverbs
you will now create a parser from nltk
dot reg exp parser
and pass the [ __ ] grammar to it now use
the new [ __ ] parser to parse the tokens
sent three and run the results as you
can see the parse tree is generated
while comparing the syntax tree of the
[ __ ] parser with that of the original
chunk
you can see that the token is quickly
adverb
chinked out of the chunk let's
understand how to use context-free
grammar
a context-free grammar is a four-tuple
sum n-t-r-s where sum is an alphabet
and each character in sum is called a
terminal
nt is a set and each element in nt is
called a non-terminal
r the set of rules is a subset of nt
times the set of sum u and t
s the start symbol is one of the symbols
in nt
a context-free grammar generates a
language l
capturing constituency and ordering in
cfg the start symbol is used to derive
the string
you can derive the string by repeatedly
replacing a non-terminal
on the right hand side of the production
until all non-terminals have been
replaced by terminal symbols
let's understand the representation of
context-free grammar through an example
in context-free grammar a sentence can
be represented as a noun
phrase followed by a verb phrase noun
phrase can be a determiner
nominal a nominal can be a noun vp
represents the verb phrase a can be
called a determiner
flight can be called a noun consider the
string below where you have certain
rules
when you look at the given context free
grammar a sentence should have a noun
phrase followed by a verb phrase
a verb phrase is a verb followed by a
noun a verb can either be saul or
met noun phrases can either be john or
jim
and a noun can either be a dog or a cat
check the possible list of sentences
that can be generated using the rules
use the join function to create the
possible list of sentences
you can check the different rules of
grammar for sentence formation using the
production function
it will show you the different tags used
and the defined context-free grammar for
the given sentence
demo 2 structuring sentences problem
statement
a company wants to perform text analysis
for one of its data sets
you are provided with this data set
named tweets.csv
which has tweets of six us airlines
along with their sentiments
positive negative and neutral the tweets
are present in the text column and
sentiments in airline underscore
sentiment column
we will be retrieving all tags starting
with at the rate
in the data set and save the output in a
file called
references.txt let us first import the
pandas library
and read the tweets data set
extract the features text and airline
sentiment
we will iterate through the data set
using reg x
find the relevant tweets
now we will import the inter tools
module it returns efficient iterators
the result is stored in a file named
references.txt
let's extract all noun phrases and save
them in a file named
noun phrases for left carrot airline
underscore sentiment
write caret review dot txt
here left carat airline underscore
sentiment
right carrot has three different values
positive negative and neutral
so three files will be created
now we will iterate all the leaf nodes
and assign them to
noun phrases variable
this means that the functions in itter
tools operate
on iterators to produce more complex
iterators using the map function we will
get
all the noun phrases from the text
putting it into list
creating a file name in the name of
review.txt
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here